hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
this is so exciting I just got this in
the mail it's actually it's almost
midnight right now and I was like I have
to unbox this because it is something
that I'm so excited about there's a few
things that I really really love number
one you know I'm a huge fan of iPhones
and have an absolute huge fan of smart
home technology another thing that I
love is video games and more
specifically destiny cheese I even
having the most fun playing this game
ever I haven't had a chance to play the
expansion because I've been super busy
getting ready for the holidays but this
little guy is the Destiny to ghost
basically this is your companion in the
game and now this can be your companion
in real life if you already have an
Alexa and you're a huge destiny fan and
this is something that I mean you've
gotta have I feel ready and my Alexa app
prepared to connect so basically you
connect the ghost to your Alexa and then
you link up your Xbox account and your
Bungie account and they are you able to
do all sorts of things if you explore
the world you can learn more about
destiny to back stories and characters
you can connect with your friends and
keep track of your clans progress to
find out things online easily manage
your characters powerful arsenal of
weapons does that basically mean I could
change up my gear using Alexa what let's
open this up take a look
set it up and see what we can see every
time I use this knife like this you guys
say it's completely unnecessary and
you're right it is but leave me alone
important read this first okay we've got
a micro USB cable this looks like just a
basic plug connect your USB to their kid
here's ghost
[Applause]
I mean is this what she he's my friend
things that you can ask ghosts what's
happening in destiny how's my clan doing
how many clan members are online how
many of our weekly engrams are completed
tell ghost a message my clan ass goes to
save my raid Laura ass goes to equip my
rainbow dot S Coast [__] my favorite
of all my gosh this is crazy
this is incredible so I met Lance
Reddick who does the voice of the Zavala
at the game of words I about freaked out
you guys didn't see that vlog I'll put a
link in the description but it was
pretty incredible oh yeah this buddy he
is powered up now okay so we're gonna
open this up and we're gonna go and
search for our skills and we're gonna
look up the ghost skill in the Alexa app
see it right here so we're gonna select
the Destiny to ghost so now we have to
link our account to our Bungie accounts
and it just use face ID and it's already
logged in me in so that's pretty awesome
Alexa tell those to activate please say
three digit serial number zero zero
would you like to know
Alexa ask ghost about the tower oh my
gosh Alexa ask ghost about the speaker
ask ghost what is my next mission garden
ghost tells me there is a problem can
they do with the tower there is a
problem that they're not actually
playing destiny right now so I'm
assuming that if I was playing it would
tell me what my next mission is and
there's a bunch of other thing that says
ghost will suggest mouth drones or other
activities based on a combination of
your characters power level and what
you've completed for the week or social
play so I can ask those to call for
backup loadout so I can oh my gosh this
is crazy so I can save unique loadouts
for all of my activities you do need
Analects
enabled device to use this so basically
I am talking to my luck so that's it
over there on my desk and then that in
turn is talking to this and it's
relaying the message through the ghost
just like magic like so that's not magic
it's the Internet well thank you guys so
much for watching I just wanted to show
you this because I was so excited about
it when I first heard about this I
thought it was kind of a joke I'm like
wait a minute so basically I'm gonna be
able to talk to ghosts in real life so I
can easily update the ghost skill on the
Alexa app so who knows what the future
of this holds let me know if you guys
been playing destiny too what light
level are you what character you playing
yes tell me everything in the comments
below cubby you guys are getting ready
for the holiday this is definitely a
super-fun gift I'll also put a link in
the description where you guys can check
this out
and I'm gonna go because now at this
point it is 12 21 so it didn't take me
that long to set up I'll see you guys in
the next video bye bye Alexa tell ghost
that I love him I'm not sure what went
wrong
maybe because that's not a command
[Music]
[Applause]